who would you consider to be the cp3 of
rap
cp3 of rap like somebody who's like
maybe doesn't get that acknowledgement
but is like an all-time great what they
do you know what i'm saying
that's a great that's a great one i'm
trying to think who's the chris paul a
rap
who is the cr right you gotta answer
that one
cause also chris paul makes everyone
around him better i'm trying to think of
that person too
you know i don't know that's a tough one
i don't know maybe somebody like 50 40.
he 40. you do he make the bae he 40. he
make the big jump for real
yeah that's hard i like that that's not
a bad one e40
yo i'll let you have that man i'll let
you have that yeah yeah i'll let you
have that bay area over there
this guy tried to tell me mag ray was
the most influential rapper of all time
no no no no you didn't say one of them
you you no no no no no no
no he said no no no you didn't say that
when we
now you're saying that because the
camera no he said
the most influential rapper ever
you're [ __ ] on drugs whatever they
smoking on in the bay we got to talk
he is one of those dudes like as you
know as the new yorker like
when you think of the bay you think of
mac dre you think about mac dre
40 but like you play this song still to
this day nobody in new york is playing
this song
crazy they go crazy yeah in a certain
part of the country they go crazy
but you can't say he's the single most
influential rapper
ever for the region
okay are you accepting defeat in the
argument
so he's more than i mean he's got an
oglinay's hat on you know
he's more influential than hove or tupac
or [ __ ] rock him
you didn't say that though [ __ ] out of
here bro you didn't say that
now you're saying that lil wayne's more
influential come on bro